antonio was the best
he was the greatest oh he's so great mr
antonio miss carla they're the sweetest
people
ever people think he's really serious i
mean i thought mr antonio is going to be
like one of those serious actors he's
not at all he's the sweetest guy he
jokes around loads
like on set okay my parents can't be
spies they're not cool enough
that's cool okay we were on set and if
he'd mess up on a line he'd go daryl i
told you
to stop messing me up like that but
totally playing with him
like after scenes he played the guitar
with us and he was just so great he was
like a dad
well you know i do have a fabulous
husband and we had a blast
i mean i think the great thing about
antonio is you know he's he's obviously
a
handsome dashing man but he's also
really funny i love just
being a little bit clumsy and i just
think
it's very important for actors in
general
to have the capacity of laughing of
themselves once in a while and
and i like that i think it's up to us
you with me
okay that was like half the fun of the
movie we got to play with gadgets and we
got to like do a whole lot of stunts
the jet pack was the best jet pack was
the coolest because we got supply of it
mommy's mimicking me mommy's mimicking
me
carmen leave a brother alone alexa was
really nice
we acted like brother and sister we
played fight
we fight sometimes but it was fun
the two concepts that defined robert
rodriguez in some way which is
movies and family and in that aspect
i just i agree with him completely so
and we are very good friends so he just
asked me to come over there and play
like a kid and that's what i did
it's funny it's much more of an acting
job than the people may think we treat
them like
almost like adult kids you know we put
them in a situation like a james bond
maybe
and how you are going to get away with
that situation how they're going to
save the parents because like what movie
is all about you know they have to
rescue
the real spice and and we treat them
smartly and they the dialogues that they
have are smart and
witty and sharp ew gross
what do you see you very funny
i know that my little baby and my
stepdaughter and
they went to see the movie with mom the
other day in los angeles and they were
fighting the hormone for whatever
and they saw the movie and and
melanie said it's amazing they are so
partners now
i just wanted to do this
oh because i remember in the movie and
how the kids
band at the end of the movie and and
with the parents and among themselves
and
and they keep that in their brain and i
think it's important you know
[Applause]
you